Patrick normand bonjour salut merci de
nous recevoir chez vous ça me fait un
grand plaisir au milieu de vos amours
la demande est encore là elle va
s'étirer en conformant
c'est un petit peu peut-être un petit
piège mais c'est en 2019 que j'ai eu 50
ans de carrière mais à cause de la
pandémie on a tout reporté deux ans tout
ça
mais je vieillis deux ans pareil
alors j'ai recommencé ma tournée
en 2022
et si je me fie à mes précédentes
ça dure trois ans quatre ans je vais
être proche sinon dépenser les 80 bon
voilà alors je me dis peut-être que ça
va moins tenter de me pencher sur des
nouvelles tournées ça m'empêche pas de
donner des spectacles à gauche à droite
aléatoire mais détourner en tant que tel
le titre toujours c'est beaucoup de
déplacements puis on est loin de chez
nous puis j'ai toujours été loin de chez
nous puis depuis la pandémie j'ai appris
à tellement aimé être chez moi que j'ai
agrandi chez nous je me suis installé
solide parce que mon but c'est pas
d'aller finir mes jours à l'hôpital ou
dans un soin palliatif je vais faire ça
ici tant que vous allez pouvoir jouer
puis donner bien sûr le niveau que vous
pouvez vous allez quand même avoir envie
de faire
heureux c'est ce qu'on que moi je peux
pas ne pas jouer j'ai eu des problèmes
avec mes mains qui semblent être
s'éloignés
provisoirement mais depuis un bout de
temps j'ai pu de mal puis j'ai pu faire
que les doigts sont en train de cracher
on voit que ma main est en train de
changer est en train de se métamorphisme
métamorphoser alors je m'enfarge dans
mes propres doigts des fois dans mon jeu
parce que je suis habitué depuis
tellement longtemps c'est votre père qui
vous a présenté
ce qu'elle est devenue l'amour de votre
vie la guitare c'est c'est d'ailleurs
une chanson la Gibson de mon père la
guêpe c'est de mon père
[Musique]
de mon cœur
avec elle a commencé
[Musique]
vous avez commencé à jouer là-dessus
puis vous êtes aperçu vite que ça allait
être une partie de votre vie en partie
c'est vrai que j'ai commencé sur la
guitare la vieille quai de mon père mon
père avait
la touche lui utilisait des grosses
cordes en plus elle la touche pour un
gamin était dur à jouer fallait qu'il
désire le petit maudit
mais c'était plus fort que moi des fois
mon père arrivait du travail puis il
m'entendait jouer en bas il disait rien
parce que je voulais il voulait pas que
je prenne sa guitare mais quand tu
m'entendais jouer
mais un jour il le mille lui-même sur
mes genoux puis il y a placé mon mes
doigts
c'est pas celle-là mais c'est la vieille
guitare de mon père pareil
j'ai placé mes placés doigts comme ça
comme ça comme ça puis là ça sonnait
comme
[Musique]
la guitare et Patrick normand forme un
couple inséparable durant toute
l'entrevue elles seront là guideront
notre chemin ensemble en ce matin de mai
chez lui paisible dans sa campagne de la
rive nord de Montréal
pour ces 50 ans de carrière il a
rassemblé avec la journaliste Carmel
Dumas ses souvenirs vous avez publié ça
il y a quelques temps pour vous les 50
ans de votre carrière vous avez dit moi
au début et j'ai essayé un peu chanteur
de charme et pas de guitare
je me
sentais pas bien dans cette habilet
j'étais loin d'être un tombeur pour les
femmes et tout alors c'est tellement pas
moi
au début s'inquiétait même vos parents
parce que ce métier-là est difficile au
début puis ça vous a pris des années
avant de vous dire je vais vivre de ça
j'ai pour plaire à mes parents j'ai
toujours fait de la musique j'allais à
l'école et si j'avais été mauvais garçon
maintenant puis je voyais de la retenue
et bien il faisait faire la tenue le
vendredi parce qu'il y avait deux
voyages de d'autobus où je râlais et
puis mais je pouvais pas
un autre tantôt il m'accordait parce que
j'allais à l'hôtel La Brosse je
travaillais le vendredi soir
de la musique
c'était fort comme moi il fallait que je
le fasse et puis que je fasse après
quand j'ai lancé l'école mon père me dit
tu lances l'école mais tu t'en vas
travailler parce que pour lui enfin la
musique alors j'allais j'allais
travailler pour plaire à mes parents
puis je faisais de la musique les fin de
semaine les soirs
à 21 ans le jeune niveau Éthier de son
vrai nom entre au restaurant de l'ancien
lutteur Claude Saint-Jean le fameux
steakhouse à Greenfield Park c'est là
qu'il fera ses classes soir après soir
et c'est là qu'il deviendra Patrick
Norman
[Musique]
Fernand Gignac sera l'un des premiers à
l'encourager les rencontres se font les
rendez-vous se prennent
1969 une première apparition télé puis
en 73 un coup du destin
[Musique]
les patrons de RCA Victor à Montréal le
choisissent pour endisquer la chanson
thème du film papillon avec Steve
McQueen et daronne
Patrick Norman vous avez eu des coups
d'accélérateur dans votre carrière vous
avez un moment des moments où on parle
la chanson papillon encore la chanson
papillon vous aurez vous aussi
le film papillon succès international un
livre extraordinaire vous recevez les
droits pour faire la version française
c'est quand même c'est que RCA pour qui
j'enregistré dans le temps ont obtenu
les droits mondiaux et ils m'ont choisi
comme interprète de la chanson je l'ai
enregistré en anglais en français et en
espagnol que je vous dis de la jouer de
même vous êtes capable
[Musique]
OK
toi qui regarde ta mère
tu es seul avec tes souvenirs
et malgré tout ce bleu tout ce vert
tu es triste
[Musique]
à mourir
mais quand tu fais les yeux
qui te parle en fait
avec l'odeur
du métro chaque
[Musique]
ah sa façon
chacun son rêve
papillon
[Musique]
je sais pas si les gens mesure des fils
je vous ai demandé de chanter ça
1973 comme 14
74 73
j'ai pris un risque je me lance sans
filer mais de toute façon rendu à mon
ange je fais tout je me lance enfiler
coût d'accélérateur donc ce sont des
années 70
il va avoir des coups durs après il va
trop de coups d'accélérateur vous avez
dit dans les j'ai trouvé ça très drôle
vous avez dit c'est comme mon ordinaire
à moi ou madame en bleu
c'est quand on est en amour
ça c'est plus facile si je demande la
jouer parce que ça vous l'avez joué un
million de fois avec moi oui ça me suit
tout le temps c'est la une de mes
chansons incontournables je ne peux pas
donner un spectacle sans faire quand on
est dans l'amour les gens ce sont des
placés ils ont payé ils sont venus me
voir chanter cette chanson qu'ils
adorent puis moi je l'adore
continuellement parce que je peux pas ne
pas en accord avec le message qu'elle
véhicule
ça fait partie de mes cordes c'est qui
je suis c'est mabilité en mode
[Musique]
dis tu crois
que l'amour t'a laissé tomber une autre
fois
et tu vois
tout en univers
s'écroule autour de toi
n'oublie pas
viens toujours le soleil après les joues
depuis
ouvre quand ton cœur cherche pas
ailleurs
coup de ski tu dis
ne laisse pas passer
[Musique]
la chance d'être aimé
cœur devient moins doux
[Musique]
quand on est un amour elle est au monde
la chance d'être aimé
ouais c'est bon
le cœur devient moins doux
quand on est en amour
chacun son métier
ça a changé votre vie cette chanson
absolument
ça a changé ma vie
tellement de différentes façons d'abord
très tard à terre ça vous a amené de
l'argent exactement ça m'a c'est la
chanson qui m'a c'est de très loin mon
plus grand succès et qui me suit encore
encore aujourd'hui voir aujourd'hui
c'est de très loin mon plus grand succès
et puis
elle s'est rendue partout j'ai entendu
des versions en allemand en espagnol
en italien je l'ai fait en anglais oui
ça a été un succès
[Musique]
ici
au Rwanda
vous le croyez pas au début j'ai eu des
gens des Rwandais qui sont qui sont
venus qui m'ont abordé puis qui m'ont
expliqué ce qu'ils avaient vécu puis que
pendant que la famille se fait massacrer
à
ma chaîne elle était cachée en tant que
petite fille bien chanté quand on est en
amour en boucle dans sa tête si
quelqu'un à qui c'est arrivé qui est
venu me raconter
c'est
plusieurs autres témoignages dans ce
sens là Michel mambara c'est lui le
premier qui m'en a parlé il y a
peut-être une vingtaine d'années
pas que j'étais une grande vedette
les gens chantent les chansons dans les
autobus
j'ai jamais été j'ai la ferme intention
d'y aller en octobre prochain
[Musique]
puis 68 je pense 69
mais si jamais le choix aujourd'hui je
ferai jamais ça je le ferai jamais
[Musique]
tu regardes au travers la fenêtre brisée
dans son livre il raconte qu'il a eu mal
d'être perçu comme écrit-il un gros qui
était une frisé mal aussi de constater
que ces chansons n'apparaissaient nulle
part dans les listes des meilleures
chansons francophones
[Musique]
vibration du cœur depuis de tes pensées
pourtant avec cette voix chaleureuse et
son talent à la guitare les grands
succès se sont enchaînés
[Musique]
elle s'en va
elle déploie ses ailes vous êtes dans
votre livre tel gros frisé qui était
c'est dur ben oui le groupe physique
dans les médias dans l'élite de ces
années là et c'était vrai parce que
j'avais de la bon point dans ce temps-là
puis je portais une perruque j'étais
caricatural mais c'est un personnage
aussi alors
ça fonctionnait
de plus de disques que toutes les grands
des élites tout ça
ils sont mis à pas trop mais mais un
moment donné mais je faisais je suis pas
plus lisse et puis il y a personne moi
mais vous dites dans les livres
si vous cherchez un coup d'œil je vous
lis le si vous jetez un coup d'œil sur
certaines ouvrages de référence portant
sur la chanson québécoise
on parle de tout le monde madame Bolduc
que 180 chansons etc aucune de Patrick
normand
ni Michel Louvain puis dit dans un autre
livre on parle de quand on est en amour
en Insignia ni plus ni moins qu'il
s'agit d'une berceuse pour paumer
décourager ça c'est venu vous chercher
quand vous regarde de haut quand même
vous affectez
n'importe qui
c'est tout simplement méchant moi je
trouve ça méchant ces choses là maudit
qu'on n'est pas dans un métier où il
faut être méchant
mais malheureusement il faut qu'on
s'adresse à des méchants souvent ça fait
qu'il faut faire avec ça vient avec la
job mais on a tellement de belles
récompenses à faire ce qu'on aime on
attire l'amour c'est indéniable on
attire l'amour on dérange au début
sûrement
puis il y en a qui déteste aussi c'est
impossible de plaire à tout le monde
alors encore jeune guitariste Patrick
normand tombe amoureux d'un son celui de
Nashville un mélange de country rock et
wester
[Musique]
mort à 29 ans qui a été un des piliers
de la musique country
[Musique]
le maître parmi les maîtres qui a
notamment produit certains albums
d'Elvis Presley et que Patrick Normand a
eu le privilège de rencontrer
[Musique]
et le prodigieux Tommy Emmanuel
spécialiste du finger picking
[Musique]
parlez-moi d'abord de vos racines
musicales country western
c'est votre grande inspiration musicale
ben c'est mes premières prises de
conscience musicale j'étais enfin là
j'entends des choses les premières
choses que j'ai réussi à me rappeler
est un jeune des premières mélodie que
j'ai retenu dans ma tête de gamins
trois ans max c'est Bergerette de
Georges Guétary
c'était une bergère qui garde ses
moutons et chaque jour sa mère lui
disait attention
Bergerette Bergerette méfie-toi du loup
il te guette il te guette héros de
partout je vais vous faire écouter
quelque chose avant indiquer je pense à
résume bien vous inspirations vos
racines vous avez fait un album
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
très près des arrangements de Hangouts
[Musique]
les chanter c'est le bonheur
il y a des affaires qu'on est content ça
c'est des albums qui ont su content moi
j'ai chanté qui je suis
[Musique]
Samarie
Patrick Norman une double chance en
commençant à animer à la télévision
bonsoir tout le monde et bienvenue à
l'émission country dans le salon des
gens
et travaille les premières années avec
René Martel son ami
[Musique]
ensuite Radio-Canada il animera pendant
plus de 10 ans pour l'amour du country à
force de
[Musique]
on est très loin du gars qu'on trouvait
Queen
le cils est repris depuis par des jeunes
le Country devient court
quand Radio-Canada vous a demandé de
faire pour l'amour du country la cire
est-ce que ça ça a été une belle
surprise dans votre écoute en premier
moi je me suis jamais considéré comme un
animateur alors
tous c'est un métier animé
faire des entrevues il faut
mais finalement je pense que je me suis
bien dépouillé je l'ai pas j'ai appris
sur le Lot puis vous êtes rentrés chez
beaucoup de monde dans le salon
c'est c'est bon j'étais un peu déçu
quand on arrêtait parce que moi à 15 ans
je voulais terminer ça
des fois
[Musique]
pour ça que les gens vous aiment Patrick
Norman vous êtes vraiment monsieur
votre père de sa gettym sera fier de
vous au moins oublié
mais mon père ma mère aussi
mais c'était pas
c'était pas des cages de
manquer dans nos vies mais je fais
beaucoup de travail
je vous souhaite la santé je vous
souhaite d'aller bien je nous souhaite
de vous entendre encore sur scène je
souhaite que vous allez m'entendre
encore longtemps merci de nous avoir
accueilli ça me fait plaisir je suis
tellement déçu de quoi c'est déjà fini
on prendra